the Majin Buu saga a section of
Dragonball that has introduced some of
the most prolific and memorable moments
of the entire series however
statistically it seems to be the least
popular arc from Akira Toriyama's
Dragonball at times it's aimless
somewhat disjointed and from start to
finish the story can be overly longed
for a lot of people last week I began
the retelling and this week I'm
finishing it we had just left things off
on a tense cliffhanger Vegeta has
sacrificed himself Goku is nowhere to be
found and Goten trunks and Gohan are
trapped inside the hyperbolic time
chamber everything sort of in the bad
way right now but before we find out how
this story ends I want to thank today's
sponsor raid shadow legends a brand new
combat centric collection RPG available
now on your smart device rainshadow
legends is one of the fastest growing
online games this year with over 10
million downloads already that's more
than the population of my country the
best part it's totally free it has
fantastic storylines really impressive
3d graphics and my personal favorite
epic boss battle encounters you face
with your champions check out the detail
on these guys my favorite is Galan
because he looks like the love child of
the Incredible Hulk and Sheamus from WWE
as I said the game is growing fast with
an all-new reward system for its players
for the first 90 days you can claim your
rewards just by logging in so what are
you waiting for if you use the special
link in the description you will get
50,000 silver and a free champion as
part of the new player program good luck
and I'll see you there now back to the
story we pick things up right as Gohan
fires a blast through Vegeta's torso
only this time we follow the point of
view of the Saiyan Prince seeing this
action take place go to them trunks dash
in to catch Vegeta right before he falls
off the edge of the lookout at this time
Vegeta is conscious but he looks at
trunks gives him a hug and tells him how
proud he is of them quite similar to the
original in fact however Vegeta does go
on to say you see that door over there I
need you to take Gohan and run inside
it's safe in there what behind the door
but what about you I you can't to hell I
can't now stop wasting time I've got to
give Buu something first I'll be in
right after you three Trump's and Goten
give a nervous nod and move quickly to
go on who's lying unconscious on the
floor supreme kai arrives in time to
witness all of this happen he sees Gohan
blast Vegeta
Goten and Trunks flight to Vegeta's aid
and he sees goku in a last-ditch effort
to summon power run out of time getting
transported back to Otherworld in a
blinding fury having lost sight of both
Gohan and Goku majin buu begins firing
in all directions around him painting
the skies these blasts erase all life on
earth in the process the entire look out
is annihilated ending the life of both
denday and mr. Popo amidst this chaos
and destruction
Bobby suddenly appears behind the
Supreme Kai you've run out of options
Kai all I have to do now is call my
precious majin buu and your dad [ __ ] a
Supreme Kai turns to face poverty his
eyes are met with the sight of an evil
wizard sliced in half in this confusion
without warning the Supreme Kai is
dragged to a rock formation on the
ground below towering alongside the Kai
with his cape billowing in the wind
stands piccolo apologies for the rough
landing but it's safer for you here
during this time supreme kai informs
piccolo of Watts become a Vegeta Goku
and the younger Saiyans in the time
chamber immediately piccolo begins to
hatch a plan you need to get to Goku
piccolo orders tell him to use the
namekian Dragon Balls and transport
Gohan and the two boys out of there with
a serious look at his face the Supreme
Kai says just grab my arm I'll take you
there myself
right as piccolo reaches for the Supreme
Kai's arm he notices a massive blast
approaching it quickly pushes the Chi
out of the way in doing so piccolo loses
his arm it's in that instant piccolo
screams for the Chi to leave right now
as he stands between him and majin buu
conflicted the Chi teleports away
leaving piccolo to fend for himself
piccolo begins to smirk you have no idea
what's coming for you monster and with
that Buu absorbs the namekian assuming
the physical traits of the warrior he -
smirks and mutters to himself oh but I
do we cut to inside the chamber Gohan is
barely conscious as Goten gives him his
energy and trunks is waiting patiently
staring at the door when suddenly it
begins to vanish seeing this trunks
panics Goten in a flash Gohan shoots up
from his bed what where how do we get
here as he runs out onto the steps
overlooking the void
Goten and Trunks Filomena what's
transpired distraught
Gohan falls to his knees looking at his
bruised and bloodied hands my mom told
me about this place she said that one
day out there is one year here
Goten looks - Gohan excited Gohan begins
to mutter as he looks back at the space
where the door once was if we stay here
for longer than two years then we're
trapped forever
Goten tries to reassure his brother we
can train here get stronger and when
they get us out we'll be ready
Gohan not listening with his eyes vacant
starts walking away from the chamber
room and into the void Goten and Trunks
ask where he's going
Gohan explains that there's no getting
out of here and that with the three of
them the food won't last a year if it's
just Goten and Trunks and the food will
last well over a year together before it
runs out Goten begins to run after him
stumbling and tripping as his foot
touches the void of the chamber he's
given a lot of his energy already to go
hon and the gravity in this chamber is
different as he struggles to keep up
with his brother he grabs onto his leg
Gohan turns super soon the force ends
Goten flying backwards
go hunt walks away there's a massive
flash of lightning surge of energy Goten
is standing comfortably with an angry
face behind him and you Super Saiyan
stop go ten screams Gohan abruptly stops
in his tracks and turns to face his
brother does anyone even know we're here
mr. Fujita does Gohan turns away and
looks to the floor it disappointed in
himself he continues to walk away wait a
dad might you said he was amazing that
he could do anything
Gohan continues to walk away go tend
falls to his knees come back in that
moment Gohan realizes what he's about to
do his hands stopped shaking his
heartrate relaxes and he runs back to
embrace his younger brother I'm so sorry
it's okay I believe in you and I've got
an idea
Goten begins to show Gohan this dance
Goku showed him at the tournament a
dance that he said could join two people
amplifying their power
Goten begins to demonstrate the poses
but he can't quite remember the specific
details of it something about angles he
said Gohan's ears perk up angles 45
degrees dentists mirror images of one
another index fingers converge 30
minutes hold on a sec I think I got it
while all of this is happening we cut to
Vegeta and Goku who are fighting boo in
Otherworld ideally I want this fight to
remain largely the same - Goku being
Super Saiyan 3 I want Vegeta to be
brought back because they needed to
bring him back I want both Goku and
Vegeta to work together in fighting
majin buu all the while trying to get
the domeki and Dragon Balls together as
the Supreme Kai told them to 12 hours
pass or six months in the chamber we cut
back to the boys training inside in
tattered rags
suddenly the door reappears in a
blinding flash of light go tanks emerges
from the chamber followed by a very
serious Gohan
out of nowhere Goku appears using
instant transmission quick take my arm
they both did exactly that and are
transported to the world of the Kai's
instantly once there they're greeted by
the image of majin buu smashing the
lifeless beaten limp body of Vegeta to
the ground repeatedly he looks different
Gohan remarks crawling behind Gohan he
finds the Supreme Kai barely clinging to
life made to watch as these events
it's not what you think it's not your
father
Vegeta Gotenks here's this but loses his
senses launching himself towards majin
buu at full power get away from him
Gohan tries to stop them but he's too
late the attack however was extremely
powerful and successful go tanks in the
blink of an eye sends majin buu straight
into a cliff face as go tank stands next
to his father without warning the body
of Vegeta begins to turn into pink Majnu
lunging at the fused warrior engulfing
and absorbing him before slithering back
to the real majin buu it's revealed that
Vegeta and Goku have been long since
defeated while the three Saiyans were in
the chamber used as puppets created by
majin buu to lure go on and go tanks
into this twisted situation through
absorbing Goku and Vegeta Buu learned of
the namekian Dragon Balls their plan to
rescue the boys and the techniques of
the two fighters without flinching Gohan
turns to his father who's standing with
his back to him slowly Goku's head
twists 180 degrees his lifeless vacant
eyes meeting Gohan's he smirks goodbye
my son
you're the reason I'm dead the pink
clone lunges at Gohan but suddenly
thanks to ash
Buu remarks he's fast boo you're right
I'm the reason my dad's dead and the
reason everyone's dead now I've let
people down I've run away and my
arrogance has led to this to you I'm the
reason and you know what else I go hard
and I'm the reason they're coming back
the only reason I'm here now is because
everyone believed in me and I am sick of
letting them down Majin Buu I'm gonna
kill you the fight between the two
warriors is spectacular with Gohan
getting the better of him on a number of
occasions at various points Gohan even
gets him to the point of regeneration
but always allows him the time to
recover
suddenly boobs physical appearance
begins to shift his energy plummets
Gohan smiles I knew there was a chance
when his energy didn't rise after
absorbing you two you guys are amazing
Vegeta piccolo Goku and the two boys now
on
fused appear outside totally free boo is
really and bewildered Vegeta and piccolo
immediately begin pressing an attack
while Buu is preoccupied Gohan grabs and
hugs his father instructing him to go to
new Namek he suspects there might be a
wish left no matter what happens I need
you to wish everyone back to reverse
this madness in that moment Goku recalls
that this is the role that Gohan had
when he asked him to leave on Namek
during his fight with Frieza Goku just
smiles and says you got it go hon Vegeta
and piccolo set up majin buu for one
final attack from Gohan just as he had
failed to do as a child against nappa
without hesitation Gohan fires an
impossibly massive kamehameha wiping
majin buu from existence using the
namekian Dragon Balls the world is
restored to normal
Gohan has grown from this experience
Goku has learned more about his son and
the world is safe once again writing
this story while fund was an incredibly
difficult Enterprise to finish in a
single week my goal was always to write
a story centered around Gohan and I
tried I know I didn't keep track of a
lot of characters and left a lot
glazed-over thought as Ernest Hemingway
said the first draft always sucks so I
asked you in the comment section what
would you change about my story how
would you improve it I mean I can think
of a few ways already with that said I
look forward to your comments and thank
you so much for watching
you
[Music]